I think Republicans can only win in
general if they become or live in let
live
hi I'm Nicolas tree with Reason TV we
are at the reboot 2014 conference and
we're talking with Senator Rand Paul
from Kentucky senator thanks for talking
to us
what can the rest of the country learn
from Silicon Valley you know I think the
amazing thing out here is the relentless
energy and drive to move forward and
they don't wait to say hey how can
government fix this problem or how can
even somebody else fix it they fix it
themselves or they find a niche like
they find taxicabs have a monopoly how
are we gonna beat the monopolies and
they start Ebor so I think to me it's
just amazing ingenuity and amazing that
they will just do it they're not
somebody else yeah I'm us I mean they're
not even thinking about government
they're getting on with their business
and I deal with it afterwards
what can the rest of the country I mean
what can Kentucky what can the
industrial Midwest what can the south
rather what can Silicon Valley learn
from other parts of the country well I
think one of the things that you know
Silicon Valley in some ways when you
know pretty Democrat they supported the
president I think they just need to
reevaluate and say all the things we do
here the success of Silicon Valley would
that happen if we had a big government
that had internet taxes internet
regulation would Silicon Valley have
ever developed if big government got in
the way of the development of the
Internet in fact some people say that
the beauty of the internet and why it's
developed so phenomenally is every other
industry that we have in the country is
heavily regulate its one of the few
industries that really has very little
regulation so why do why do you think
that the Silicon Valley has it's gotten
more politicized at least since the
Microsoft antitrust case in the early
2000s but why is it why has it gone so
Democratic then you know I think they're
not completely comfortable in either
party and I know you and Matt have
written about you know the demographics
of where people are and I truly believe
the conclusion that a plurality of
people for no longer Republican or
Democrat and Silicon Valley I would put
right in that sort of demographic if you
ask people out here are you more
fiscally conservative less taxes than
the president less regulation they'll
say yeah I'm more conservative than
president are you more moderate or
liberal on social issues than the
Republicans yes so they don't fit neatly
in either category
but I think they're also primed for
someone who come to them with a message
that is not entirely Republican and not
entirely Democrat you talked to you gave
a speech here at the reboot conference
and you were talking about how
regulation you know a company like uber
or there were many Internet services
they create their own regulation where
both the drivers and the riders are
being regulated does that kind of new
model of regulation work saying you know
in the Kentucky coal industry can you do
that kind of new form of regulation in
older-style industries I don't know
that's a good question but I mean there
is a question of things they call
externalities that there isn't a direct
way the two parties regulated was the
third party it's being affected like my
air pollution and things I think many
libertarians have written over time that
property rights should be able to stop
pollution or limit pollution although it
is fairly complicated because in the
sense that we is not an all-or-none
sometimes society will tolerate
something like we all drive cars and we
all have electricity so there is some
emissions and we have to as a society
develop what is acceptable could that be
done by the crowd responding to your
pollution I'm not positive but I do
think that there are many things where
government becomes overzealous and
regulations whereas the crowd people who
buy stuff and then judge how well you
sell it to me they want the product but
they also want a good product that's
honest without fraud and without safety
concerns so I think there is a role and
it's a better role for the crowd to
regulate things than government because
government only knows the downside of
regulation they don't look at the upside
of employment and distribution of
products I talk a little bit about
benefit corporations you've you've been
speaking a lot about that and that seems
to be very much in tune with Silicon
Valley or a kind of tech community what
is a benefit corporation and why do you
think they're important a benefit
corporation allows a corporation to do
something they think is good for the
environment or just good for people and
they don't have to look as strictly at
their bottom line to me it kind of goes
along with the freedom argument that if
you own your business you tell your
shareholders what you're gonna do you're
either going to always maximize profit
or you're going to mostly maximize
profit and sometimes we're going to do
things for the environment
I think businesses should have that
freedom so I've supported something
called a B corporation that allows you
to file and say you know what sometimes
we're just going to do something that's
a little more expensive when we get rid
of our waste we're gonna do it because
we believe in keeping the environment
this seems to be part of a broader
social movement where work and you talk
to hutch on this in your comments work
is a form of self-expression now in a
way that may not have been 50 or 60
years ago well to me you know if you
talk about that the health of the psyche
or the health of the soul I think works
in an amazing thing and an amazing part
of it because it's a it's an integral
part of what like John Allison says in
Cato of earned self-esteem right no one
can give you self-esteem self-esteem is
important we've got a culture that logs
self-esteem if they want to give it to
everybody and it's like 2+2 is 5 volt
Johnny that we want you to feel good
about that it's oh no Johnny needs to
learn if 2 plus 2 is 4 and then he can
feel good about and then he'll get sail
he'll earn his self-esteem but it's also
that really our culture we need to try
to reinforce with people how important
work is not as punishment but as reward
and so from a governmental point of view
I want people to know that I want
everybody to work and then I will have
plans that everybody will work but not
as punishment but as a reward a foreign
policy is an issue that you you or
you're at loggerheads a lot with not
just establishment Democrats like Barack
Obama or Hillary Clinton but with other
members of the Republican Party like
John McCain Chris Christie Rick Perry
recently what is your foreign policy
vision and how do you answer people to
say you know what you're a namby-pamby
isolationist it just wants to lock
everything into a fortress America
usually anybody that uses the word
namby-pamby we fight yes if you say that
again all right it probably will be
fisticuffs but no seriously I think the
federal government the number one
priority of the federal government is
defending the country it is in the
Constitution it's constitutional it's a
priority and for me if you ask me when
tax dollars are sent by the people to
Washington where's the priority to meet
the priority is in defending the country
now when we get beyond that then we
would say well how often should we be
involved enough
civil war in Syria right I think there's
a spectrum of foreign policy from that
we're never involved anywhere in the
world where we're always involved
everywhere in the world I think for many
years particularly the last dozen or so
we've been very close to everywhere all
the time but I think there have been
times in our history
Eisenhower Reagan the first George Bush
where we were much more towards the
middle where we said you know what war
is the last resort when we go we we we
vote on it in Congress the people's
representatives have to vote that's what
the Constitution says we go reluctantly
or as as Reagan said in one of his first
inaugural switch I really like he said
to potential adversaries he says don't
mistake our lack of our reluctance for
war for a lack of resolve and I think
that's a good way of putting it that we
should be reluctant for war and I think
America wants someone who will defend
the country but they also someone who's
wise and is not eager for how can this
be a hard sell to Republicans and it
seems to be I mean to the establishment
they're like no this is all wrong I mean
Dick Cheney is having as you know 5th
through 10th heart attack every time you
say something I think a few people in
Washington don't really represent even
the Republican movement if you ask
people right now should we send American
GIs back into Iraq a majority of
Republicans say no in fact my allegation
or what I would allege is that if we had
a hundred American soldiers who are
volunteers and they were sitting here in
the audience and we asked them do you
think we should go back and that you
should be sent back I think they'd say
no now so I think really the the opinion
has shifted but the policymakers I think
there are a lot of times a decade behind
the rest of the public is it gonna be
hard to untangle the military-industrial
complex that Eisenhower and other people
warned about because when you start to
say you know what and you and the budget
planes you put out it's not like you
decrease defense baseline defense
spending either by much if at all but
the contractor is all of the people who
are on the tit for military industrial
work I mean that's a lot of money you
know even like today I ran into a guy
says I was military my sons military
worried about a strong national defense
even this gentleman when I say you know
that I believe it's a priority but then
I say you know what we should ought it
the Pentagon because we can't have a
strong national defensive we're paying
$1,000 for a hammer or $1,000 for a
toilet seat so we do have to even if you
do believe national defense which I do
is a priority you can't write unlimited
checks because you'll bankrupt the
country in the quickest way to you know
sort of the decline and fall of America
is bankruptcy you know people have said
that the biggest threat to our national
security is bankruptcy so really I think
believing in responsible spending even
for military is a strong national
defense position reason recently did a
poll of Millennials the national poll
only 22% call themselves Republican or
lean that way
Millennials there's 80 million of them
they're gonna be the you know they're
the future demographically politically
of the country they're in favor of gay
marriage they're in favor of pot
legalization they're in favor of vaping
they're in favor of online gambling can
the Republican Party shed the social
conservative issues which seem very
central to its concerns and and get with
Millennials or how is that going to work
and they win Millennials without
becoming more libertarian I think
Republicans can only win in general if
they become more live-and-let-live leave
me alone the leave me alone Grover
Norquist will talk about the sometimes
this leave me alone coalition but the
coalition in order to work and this is
what a lot of people don't realize they
say oh well we want Republicans just to
be the pro-choice pro-gay marriage party
it may not be that but it may be that
there will be people in the Republican
Party who have those positions and some
who don't and that we kind of all get
along because we believe in limited
government and then we acknowledge you
know what maybe the federal government's
not gonna be involved in some of these
issues anyway and I think that live and
live agree to disagree kind of
amalgamation of people in the party will
allow us to be big enough to win and I
agree with you like on young people but
I think also some other libertarian
issues like the right to privacy the NSA
overzealousness and overbearing NSA
young people are concerned about the
cell phone that's the main thing they
deal with every hour of every day and I
think if we became the party that is
going to protect their privacy I think
that you could get us a large switch of
Republican vote from youth vote for
final question
the export-import bank is coming up for
reauthorization this is an FDR program
from the mid 30s that helps subsidize
purchases of American goods in the
Soviet Union it is one of the great
clear cases of crony capitalism you
voted against reauthorization in 2012
are you going to vote against
reauthorization again yes or no
absolutely and I think that's a big part
of if I'm a Republican I'm going out and
saying you know what we have limited
resources and we can't have everyone on
food stamps by golly I need to be a
Republican also says we're not giving
one penny of corporate welfare so I'm
not forgiving corporate welfare and I
think a lot of people if they knew that
we had to cut all of the corporate
welfare in order to have a more
reasonable government that can pay for
itself I think all the sudden people
will say you know what that's an honest
Republican what they don't like is a
Republican who says you know what I'm
cutting the food stamps but by golly I'm
keeping the corporate welfare that's an
untenable position and Republicans need
to cast that off well we'll leave it
there thank you Senator Rand Paul of
Kentucky for talking to Reason TV at the
reboot 2014 conference I'm Nikolas
Nadeau